we're just too tied down nothing else to
do
and uh hold your bank and now now now
finally i have been
thinking about this kind of checkmating
idea for a long time is it gonna be
happening soon okay white work we were
thinking maybe the white rook at the
bottom of the board could swing over at
some point and start checking the black
king but you can maybe step up with the
king actually oh the rook as well i mean
it's going to be two pawns up isn't it i
think and yeah like it even moves great
yeah
one at least one of those two black
horns is going to drop now yeah
oh no and jordan with his oh he looks so
sad yeah
it's very sad but it's been a good day
for him three wins so far but probably
ending up with a loss he needed a good
day jordan yesterday was a bit of a
disaster and there we go a result where
he takes the win another win for way wow
what a tournament he is having in his
very first event in the milwaukee
champions uh chess tour he is on top of
the table winning another game